This lecture is about the latent aspect
rating analysis or opinion mining and
sentiment analysis.
In this lecture, we're going to
continue discussing opinion mining and
sentiment analysis.
In particular, we're going to
introduce.
Late in the aspect of rating analysis,
which allows us to perform detailed
analysis of reviews with overall
ratings.
First, motivation.
Here are two reviews that you often see
on the Internet about the Hotel and
You see some overall ratings.
In this case, both reviewers have given
five stars.
And of course there are also reviews
that are in text.
Now, if you just look at these reviews,
it's not very clear whether a hotel is
good for its location or for its
service, and it's also unclear why are.
If you are like this hotel.
So what we want to do is to decompose
this overall rating.
Into ratings on different aspects such
as value, rooms, location and service.
So if we can decompose overrating two
ratings on these different aspects.
Then we can obtain more detailed
understanding of the reviewers opinions
about the hotel.
And this would also allow us to rank
hotels along different dimensions, such
as valuable rooms, but in general such
detailed understanding would reveal
more information about the users,
preferences, reviews, preferences and
also we can understand better how
reviewers view this hotel from
different perspectives.
Now, not only do we want to.
Infer this aspect ratings.
We also want to infer the aspect of
weights, so some reviewers may care
more about values as opposed to
service, and that would be a case like
what's shown on the left for the weight
distribution where you can see a lot of
weight is placed on value.
But others might care more about
service and therefore they might place
more weight on service then value.
Now, the reason why this is also
important that is be cause do you think
about a five star on value?
It might still be very expensive if the
reviewer cares a lot about service,
right?
For this kind of service, this price is
good, so the reviewer might give it a
five star.
But if reviewer really cares about the
value of the hotel, then the five star
most likely would mean really cheaper
prices.
So in order to interpret the ratings on
different aspects accurately, we also
need to know these aspect weights.
When they are combined together, we can
have a more detailed understanding of
the opinion.
So the task here is to get these
reviews and their overall ratings as
input and then generate the both the
aspect ratings, decomposed aspect
ratings and the aspect of weights as
output.
And this is a problem called latent
aspect rating analysis.
So the task in general is given a set
of review articles about the topic with
overall ratings.
An we hope to generate the three
things.
One is the major aspects comment on in
the reviews.
The second is the ratings on each
aspect, such as value and room or
service.
And 3rd is the relative weights placed
on different aspects by the reviewers,
and this task has a lot of
applications.
If we can do this and we would enable a
lot of applications, I just listed some
here and later.
I will show you some results.
And for example, we can do opinion
based and the ranking.
We can generate a aspect level opinion
summary.
We can also analyze reviewers
preferences, compare them or compare
their preferences on different hotels.
And we can do personalized
recommendation of products.
So of course the question is how can we
solve this problem?
Now, as in other cases of these
advanced topics, we won't have time to
really cover the technique in detail,
but I'm going to give a press basic
introduction to the technique developed
for this problem.
So first we're going to talk about how
to solve the problem in two stages.
Later, we're going to also mention that
we can do this in the unified model.
Now take this review with the overall
reading as input.
What we want to do is first we're going
to segment the aspects.
So we're going to figure out what words
are talking about location in what words
are talking about, the room conditioning,
etc.
So with this we would be able to obtain
aspect segments.
In particular, we're going to obtain
the counts of all the words in each
segment, and this is denoted by C
supply of WND.
This can be done by using seed words
like location and room.
Or price to retrieve the relevant the
segments and then from those segments
we can further mine correlated words.
With these seed words and that would
allow us to segment the text into
segments.
Discussing different aspects, but of
course later as we would see, we can
also use topic models to do the
segmentation, But anyway, that's the
first stage where we would obtain the
counts of words in each segment.
In the segmentation stage, which is called
latent rating regression, we're going
to use these words and their
frequencies in different aspects to
predict the overall rating, and this
prediction happens in two stages.
In the first stage, we're going to use
the sentiment weights of these words in
each aspect to predict the aspect
rating.
So, for example, if in the discussion
of location using a word like amazing
mentioned many times and it has a high
weight.
For example, here is 3.9.
Then it would increase the aspect
rating for location.
But another word, like a far, which is
a negative weight if it's mentioned
many times and it will decrease the
rating.
So the aspect rating is assumed to be a
weighted combination of these word
frequencies where the weights are the
sentiment weights on the words.
Now of course these sentiment weights
might be different for different
aspects.
So we have for each aspect a set of
sentiment weights.
As shown here, and that's denoted by
beta sub I and W.
In the second stage, or in a second
step, we're going to assume that the
overall rating is simply weighted
combination of these aspect ratings.
So we're going to assume we have aspect
weights in order by of R sub of D.
And this would be used to take a
weighted average of the aspect ratings,
which are denoted by our supply of the.
And we can assume the overall rating is
simply a weighted average of this
aspect ratings.
So this setup allows us to predict the
overall rating based on the observed
word frequencies.
So on the left side you will see all
these observed information, the arts,
the and the count.
But on the right side you see all the
information that we're interested in is
actually latent.
So we hope to discover them.
Now this is a typical case of
generating model where we would embed
the interesting variables in the
generating model.
And then we're going to set up a
generation probability for the overall
rating given the observed words.
And then of course, then we can adjust
these parameter values including
betas, rs, alpha i.
In order to maximize the probability of
the data in this case, the conditional
probability of the observed rating
given the document.
And so we have seen such cases before
in, for example, PLSA, where we predict
the text data.
But here we predicting the rating and
the parameters of course are also very
different.
But if you can see if we can uncover
these parameters, that would be nice
because also R of D is precisely the
aspect ratings that we want to get, and
these are decomposer ratings on
different aspects of our sub ID is
precisely the aspect weights that we
hope to get.
As a bi product that will also get the
beta vector and these are the aspects
of specifica sentiment, weights of
words, so more formally.
They thought we are modeling.
Here is a set of review documents with
overall ratings.
And each review documents denoted by AT
and overall rating is denoted by R
sub D and these pre segmented into K as
their segments and we're going to use C
sub W and D and to denote the count of
world W in aspect segment I.
Of course it's zero if the world
doesn't occur in the segment.
Now the model is going to predict the
rating based on the.
So we are interested in the conditional
probability of R sub T given D.
And this model is set up as follows.
So all of this is assumed to follow a
normal distribution with a mean that
denotes actually await the average of
the aspect ratings.
R sub of D as shown here is normal
distribution has a variance of or
square.
Now of course, this is just what our
assumption in the actual reading is not
necessary generating this way.
But as always when we make this
assumption, we have a formal way to
model the problem, and that allows us
to compute interesting quantities.
In this case, the aspect ratings and
aspect of weights.
Now the aspect rating as you see on the
second line is assumed to be weighted
sum of these weights where the weight
is just sentiment wait.
So.
As I said, the overall rating is
assumed to be a weighted average of
aspect ratings.
Now this alpha
Values of a alpha sub of D
together by our vector that depends on
D is the document specific weights and
we can assume this factor itself is
drawn from another multivariate
Gaussian distribution with mean denoted
by a mule vector and covariance matrix
Sigma, yeah.
Now, so this means when we generate our
overall rating, we're going to first
draw.
A set of other values from this
multivariate Gaussian prior
distribution and once we get these
alpha values were going to use, then
the weighted average of aspect ratings
as the mean here to use the normal
distribution.
And to generate the overall rating.
Now the aspect rating as I just said is
the sum of the sentiment weights of
words in their spectrum.
Note that here the sentiment weights
are specifically to aspects, so beta is
indexed by I.
And As for aspect.
And that gives us way to model
different segment of award.
This is neither because of the same
word might have positive sentiment for
once back, but negative sentiment for
another aspect.
It's also useful to then see.
What premise we have here, but I just
said that the beta sub I W gives us a
aspect specific sentiment of W.
So obviously that's one of the
important parameters, but in general we
can see we have these parameters.
The beta values that Delta and then the
mu and Sigma.
So next question is, how can we
estimate these parameters and so we
collectively denote all the parameters
by Lambda here.
Now we can, as usual, use
The maximum likelihood is made and this
will give us the settings of this
premise that with the maximizer
observed.
Observer ratings condition on their
respective reviews.
And of course, this would then give us
all the useful variables that will
interest in computing.
So now more specifically, we can now
once we estimate the parameters, we can
easily compute the abstract rating for
aspect I or sub I of D and that's
simply to take all the words that
occurred in the segment I and then take
their accounts and then multiply that
by the sentiment weight of each word
and take a sum.
So of course this counter would be 04
words that are not occurring in the
aspect I, and that's why we can take
some over all the words in the
vocabulary.
Now, what about the aspect weights?
Alpha sub I of D?
It's not part of our parameter, right?
So we have to use Bayesian inference to
compute it.
And in this case we can use the maximum
a posteriori.
2 computer this alpha value.
Basically we're going to maximize the
product of the prior of our according
to our assumed market valued Gaussian
distribution and the likelihood in this
case likely is the probability of
generating this observed overall rating
given this particular Alpha value and
some other parameters.
As you see here.
So for more details about this model,
you can read this paper cited here.